- There's a tremendous amount of good
that Neuralink can do in
solving critical damage
to the brain or the spinal cord.
There's a lot that can be done to improve
quality of life of individuals,
and those will be steps along the way.
And then ultimately,
it's intended to address
the risk, the existential risk,
associated with digital
super-intelligence.
We will not be able to be smarter than
a digital super-computer,
so therefore, if you cannot
beat them, join them.
And at least we want to have that option.
- So you have hope that
Neuralink will be able to be
a kind of connection to allow us to merge,
to ride the wave of improving AI systems?
- I think the chance
is above zero percent.
- [Lex] So it's non-zero.
There's a chance.
- Have you seen Dumb and Dumber?
- Yes, yes.
- [Elon] So I'm
saying there's a chance.
- You're saying one in a billion,
one in a million, whatever
it was in Dumb and Dumber.
- You know, it went from
maybe one in a million
to improving, maybe it'll
be one in a thousand
and then one in a
hundred, then one in ten.
Depends on the rate of
improvement of Neuralink
and how fast we're able to make progress.
- Well, I've talked to a few folks here
and they're quite brilliant
engineers, so I'm excited.
- It's important that
Neuralink solves this problem
sooner rather than later,
because the point at which
we have digital super-intelligence,
that's where we pass the Singularity,
and things become very uncertain.
Doesn't mean that they're
necessarily bad or good,
but the point at which
we pass Singularity,
things become extremely unstable.
So we want to have a human brain interface
before the Singularity,
or at least not long after it,
to minimize existential risk for humanity
and consciousness as we know it.